was this young woman she's my
Oh Diana Princess of lemon Prince Diana
Prince
the first time we're going to sell her
story this superhero who's so iconic I
cannot stand by while innocent lives are
lost she is kind and loving and
forgiving and about out tough luck
so there's nothing not to love
[Music]
the gods gave us many gifts one day
you'll know them all
I'm a big believer in the origin story
it's beautiful
who would really only the fiercest among
us even could and that is not you Diana
there's something so exciting about
where she comes from and what that
history isn't of the Amazon are you will
training harder than any Amazon before
her five times harder anytime is harder
never let your guard down you expect the
battles will be bad until she is better
than even you
but she must never know the truth about
what she is the story of is well Diana
becoming Wonder Woman and owning it for
the first time she has this urge to want
to do good and want to help Steve Trevor
is a pilot and he's a spy and he crashes
off the coast of the mascara what is
this place who are you people
we are the bridge to a greater
understanding right what is your mission
well here's the thing where were you are
you are in more danger than you think it
calls into question the responsibility
do they help mankind from the moment
that Steve comes to the island she feels
that she has to help if no one else will
defend the world that I must she's
guided by the values of good of truth
and justice if you choose to leave and
they never return who would I be if I
say so Steve Trevor ends up being the
siren song that brings Diana out into
the world
welcome to jolly ol London here yeah
it's not for everybody
when she first gets to London and soul
gray and rainy and dirty which is a fish
out of water you know what are you doing
you don't because you don't wearing any
don't bring any clothes let's go go fly
you suppose this is a young naive woman
thank god you're not damaged means
coming into the world with the best of
intentions better candy and see Travis
six days
what is it secretary well I do ever
think I go where he tells me to go I do
what you tells you to do or and where
I'm from that's called slavery I really
like her the coming of Diana to the
men's world is a very amusing revolution
for her yep that's not gonna work please
put the sword down it doesn't go with
the outfit at all the way that our two
characters intersect is I am that jaded
realist we've seen the evil of the world
and she shows me that there's still room
for idealism Dinah we have to go hate to
house these people you can't save
everyone about me you say that what is
the matter with wit this is no man's
land this is not something you can cross
it's not possible not what we came here
to do so what I'm going to do what is it
to be a hero the greatest thing about
Wonder Woman is how good and kind and
loving she is yet none of that negates
any of her power
[Music]
the beautiful thing about Wonder Woman
is that she's so many different things
she can be sensitive and the greatest
warrior ever and strong and confused
like she can be all of the above in a
beautiful way
yeah man yeah I mean look like one gal
embodies everything about Wonder Woman
gal is genuinely such a kind lovely
thoughtful person so she is what Wonder
Woman stands for if you never met a man
before what about your father
I had no father my mother's husband is
from play and I was lucky laughs thank
you
relax neat gal she's one of the best
personalities I've ever encountered she
is without fail positives and such a
hard worker
I had five months of doing horse riding
and martial arts and a lot of body work
working with gallon with Sun team and
show the evolution of Diana skills and
her understanding her inner power she's
using the lasso and blocking all the
bows I was so lucky to work with people
that I admire and am inspired by as
exhausting as it was I was ready we were
shooting outside of Oxford in England
and oh god it was cold
all of us are stacked up in our wool
uniforms in this gal she did the scene
didn't complain Danna can't be cold
she's Wonder Woman I think that because
I was so focused on telling her story
and being her that I literally depressed
the physical challenges stay here I'll
go ahead she is just the monster
[Music]
[Applause]
too much wine ice cream thank you I took
pleasure there you go folks with the
change thank you very much sir
we're they it's wonderful yeah you
should be very proud
thank you very much you should be very
proud Chris is such a gift to this movie
because he gave an integrity to Steve
Trevor Steve Trevor is intrinsic to her
storyline so we needed to find the
perfect guy and Chris is so honorable
hilarious charming
Chris had so much experience he's been
doing this for years and he guides me
through this world in such a comfortable
way the two of them together made
something really special
[Applause]
hi okay perfect what I can barely
remember what first attracted me to
Wonder Woman because it was so natural
it happened when I was such a young
child so I was attracted to the
character as soon as I ever heard about
her and still AM
Patti's had a long history with Wonder
Woman and we realized that totally what
we were looking for was exactly the
movie that she wanted to make Betty
Jenkins Wow
I am so lucky that Patti was the one to
direct this movie and provision for
Diana was in line with mine she is such
a brilliant talented person and to be
able to work with someone who is so
funny and loving and warm so amazing
bring the energy back is that
performance yeah the first thing that
strikes you about her is her incredible
energy that was awesome Patti is a
pretty incredible human being when she
acted out essentially the entire film
she is so passionate
so look up the film is the one that I
really believe in because I think she
deserves grand cinema so it was
wonderful designing not only the
character Diana but also creating an
entire culture basically of people and
what they dress like and what they look
like in what materials they make I was
thrilled that there was a balance in the
film between the slightly fantastical
world that the Amazons were going to
inhabit and a much more deprived gray
world of the war film is a collaborative
art form in you're only as good as the
people around you and I really had not
been on anything that has had quite the
insane Bret and depth craftsmanship as
this for a choice of the color palette -
shooting on film a period film a world
war one movie has very specific visual
language but this is a modern film that
just happens to be set in World War one
this film is slightly nicking that we
have a huge amount of locations for a
movie of this scale we have got hopping
in a region of 38 locations across two
countries Australia House comes to mind
she'll be doctors going to look
fantastic as David ox till report which
we have noise up the turkey Kings Cross
was another challenge we closed down two
platforms we bought a period 1940
vintage trainers and we've got some
glorious locations in Italy we shot the
mask your own beautiful lethal
and you know I've seen the girls and
they always look so beautiful and so
strong but when we shot the first scene
and all the women are riding horses
together
I was holding Patti's shoulder watching
the monitor and I told her I can't
believe we're shooting this I've never
seen anything like this
okay ladies ready in 3 2 1 we had been
working non-stop together in the gym ad
source training
one on the horses and and all the other
stunt training and then all of a sudden
you realize has become a beast
I am so strong right now watching women
wield a sword like that on a fork
it was great to show you can still be
strong and still be a woman the people
that we brought together to work on the
film no matter what the problems they
worked in the level of excitement and
the passion and what Wonder Woman meant
was nothing like anything I ever
experienced and
everything about one rose Cabella there
is an absolute that she will waver from
she just sees the world in a very pure
way
it's a giant myth in its best form and I
think it's very modern telling of this
story bringing out your own Wonder Woman
bringing out the best in you is an
amazingly universal thing that would
small strive for we love stories about
being something better than oneself and
willing to fight who those who cannot
fight for them
and that's the great thing about what a
superhero movie can be thrilling fun
exciting and bring out the best in you
I am jno famous Kyra daughter of
Hippolyta in the name of all that is
good field rest upon this one is over
[Music]
you
you